couple days ago Hillary Clinton posted a
tweet blaming Donald Trump's supporters
for the fact that the temperature has
gone up this summer here it is quote not
enough for you thank a mega Republican
or better yet vote them out of office
now you might recall that Maga
Republicans is an epithet that appeared
out of nowhere about a year ago when
Democratic party Consultants made it up
and already these Maga Republicans are
affecting the weather simply by existing
how are they doing that one of the
articles that Hillary Clinton cites in
her tweet was published in Forbes and
the piece reported that quote July 4th
was Earth's hottest day in over 100
000 years now that's that's quite a
claim since we've only been able to
track temperatures for the past 140
years according to NASA quote there are
too few Data before 1880 for scientists
to estimate average temperatures for the
entire planet that's what NASA says